I wanted to kill Muslims now I am one
that is [ __ ] crazy so let's get right
into it I get a knock at the door and
here uh two guys in a suit I'm from the
FBI the first thing I have to say is
what took you guys so long I told him
the truth I was gonna make my own IED
and I was gonna set across the Islamic
Center over in A bank's parking lot and
I was gonna dial it in and just watch
the show
okay what did he just say he was kind of
what blow up a mosque he was gonna blow
up a mosque and he's just saying that
yeah let's go come on what the [ __ ]
that's like
growing up I saw a movie and it was
Rambo Rambo was tough
respected he had an intestinal fortitude
[Music]
I said that's what I want to do I went
off and joined Marine Corps
I call him I wanted the action the first
time I got shot at I remember looking at
my watch and I says man this time last
year I was in English class but I fought
several times in the Middle East Desert
Shield Desert Storm South America
Philippines Somalia I think the worst
things that I have seen is dead children
I had to suck it up I had to be there
for my guys
each one of those teardrops stands for
his confirmed kill
I stopped adding after 26.
where I was taught Marine Corps just to
own it and then let it go but there
comes a time when there's too much of
that and you can't turn it off anymore I
want you to give me a window into your
state of mind at that time
wow that is so sad tattooing on your
body the people you kill that's just
like horrible like that's just I I just
would never want to look at life like
that that's crazy [ __ ]
one time my wife and I went to a DSW and
I saw in the distance these two women in
black burkas
in my store
I cried as I prayed
for enough strength to go over there and
break both the necks
I was angry I was just full of hate and
it just fed off itself
at that point I was drinking half gallon
of vodka every two days
I had devised the plan create my own IED
homemade bomb and I was going to set it
off right outside the Muncie Islamic
Center
200 plus killed or injured that was the
plan
I saw an opportunity to do one last
thing for my country this was my
rationale I knew I would end up in the
federal prison with a needle in my arm I
didn't care my hatred of Islam it was
the only thing that was keeping me alive
so one day my daughter comes home second
grade maybe she was telling me about
this little boy who sat across from her
his mom came to get him she she said she
had scarves on her and she had a dress
all the way down to her feet and she
couldn't see her on nothing but her
eyeballs at that point I snapped started
spewing things out of my mouth that
should never be said in front of
children or anything she didn't say
anything it was the look on her face I
remember my daughter looking at me like
I was absolutely the craziest person on
the face of the Earth she was my little
buddy and she used to say we were Road
dogs
I know I I saw it in her eyes I made her
question that love
and that's when the light bulb came on
I decided to give the people of this
community one more chance
[Music]
so I went to the Islamic Center see a
gentleman in the shoe room taking off
his shoes he looks at me and he smiles
he said can I help you and I said yeah I
want you to teach me about Islam so he
went and gave me a Quran read this come
back when you have questions so I did
and I would see things in the book I'd
be like there it is I got him right
there he's playing that to me and they
would
this was a kind of Awakening long story
short eight weeks after that first day I
stepped into the Islamic Center I became
a Muslim
[Music]
hello
three years later I love how he went I'd
ask to explain this and they would
that's funny that's that's a crazy story
the most open-minded like light freaking
switch changing like looking at you okay
how do you go from planning to murder
200 plus innocent people women children
old people men fathers to be even saying
even being able to say like you know
you're still trying to catch them like
but but even being able to have a
conversation with them that leap alone
is the most amazing amazing amazing
thing for a human being to be able to do
no matter who you perceive your enemy to
be that's crazy amazing this is crazy I
hope this is true you're so heartbroken
if it wasn't
veteran
and a proud American
I had learned that I was completely
wrong about everything that I felt you
know Judaism had a message Christianity
had a message Islam had a message funny
thing is though it was the same message
it's about peace and it was about love
please join me in welcoming Mr McKinney
my big thing is now to stop the hate
nothing good has ever come down to
hatred I've done too many things I've
heard a lot of people I have to live
with that
but if I can stop somebody else on the
path of non-forgiveness I want it God
damn that is a crazy story I can't
believe he was like genuinely planning
to plant a bomb that's a wild thought I
didn't even know what to say to that I
accepted like I said it's just amazing
that somebody's heart can be changed
that much that they can sit not only sit
with their enemy perceived enemy but
become their enemy once they realize
that their enemy is not an enemy at all
that's something matrix it's the Matrix
that's like this is exactly what we talk
about where it's like why do you have
these thoughts you know you can't even
rationalize or explain why it's just
like implanted in your brain so you have
to step back and really think about this
stuff it's crazy and it goes deeper than
just Islam you refuse to arrest this is
just another thing that I'm I'm looking
into I'm like wow I can't believe Matrix
programming got to me in this sense too
you know what I mean like it's why it's
everywhere if we continue on this path
where we're learning more and more about
this and for me it's it's really because
being a Christian and really loving the
fact of how my Christianity is affecting
me for me this is really about finding
the the commonalities right now I can't
wait to watch this again in a year and
see what we think when we know more you
know and we have evolved I would like to
watch this exact video in a year because
I feel like I'll have a lot more to say
about it what really matters is that a
violent angry person became a loving
accepting person and that's about
tolerance so that was a Christian whose
tall tolerance taught him that Islam is
a good thing Tate needs to see that
that's what Christianity does you know
what's crazy is that he mentioned how
they all believe in the same thing
essentially and I've just never heard
that from any other religion I've never
heard that you'd be like this is like a
totally new thing to me it's like you
believe in the same thing like I've
always looked at different religions
like Islam is like you literally believe
in a whole different God I didn't know
Jesus was in the Quran or even the most
spoken about prophet in the Quran like
but even with Judaism and Christianity I
always knew that there were that we were
basically believed in the same God and
the Christians we believe the Old
Testament the Jews just stop at the Old
Testament and they believe that you know
Jesus I didn't even know exactly what
they believe about Jesus they just don't
believe that he was the Messiah from God
but learning more about Christianity now
and you know and I say it again and
again I love love love love the TV show
The The Chosen it starts with when Jesus
hits seen as an adult and the impact he
makes and there's a so much Old
Testament and Judaism in there and so
much more that it's making me feel more
connected with with the Jewish religion
also in a way that you know some of the
things I knew but it is going so much
deeper for me learning about the Old
Testament and when you watch that you
think your mind is bugging out now
you're going to be like holy [ __ ] and
you're gonna see all these dots
connecting and on these religions and
how we're all just so divided for no
reason is Christianity the one is
Judaism the one is Islam the one maybe
there's a fourth religion where it's all
everybody combines that we haven't seen
yet we don't know so you know what does
Tate say about Islam it's the last the
last religion yeah well he doesn't know
he doesn't have a crystal ball there
might be something past this where we're
all really truly together yeah if you
guys want to drop videos for us to react
to you can post it inside of my Discord
server I have a whole Channel just for
you to post videos to react to that's
where I found this video drop us up we
want to hear from you guys we want to
talk more about this drop us up and I'll
see you later
[Music]
[Music]